nos han dado información muy interesante
sobre las funciones f g y h nos dicen
por ejemplo para la función f
algunos de sus valores por ejemplo nos
dicen que x cuando vale 0 la función
vale 2 cuando x vale 1 vale 1 cuando x
vale 4 la función vale menos 2 y así
sucesivamente también nos dieron
información sobre su derivada por
ejemplo que cuando x vale 0 la derivada
vale menos 3 o que cuando x vale 16 la
derivada vale 4 muy bien entonces esta
es la información que nos proporcionan
respecto a la función f por otro lado
nos definen a la función g de x como el
valor absoluto de x menos 1 más 1 muy
bien y finalmente tenemos una función h
h de x está definida como 3 por fx + 2
por gm x entonces la pregunta es la
siguiente cómo podemos nosotros calcular
la derivada con respecto de x
la función hdx en el punto x igual a 9
muy bien entonces como siempre te invito
a que hagas una pausa al vídeo y pienses
cómo resolver este problema antes de que
nosotros lo hagamos
y entonces nada más para para ir
aclarando cuál es la notación esto es
exactamente lo mismo que la h
prima evaluada en el punto 9 verdad
esta es la notación utilizando está
digamos este apóstrofe o esta comilla ok
entonces utilizando esta anotación
puedes utilizar cualquiera de las dos
más bien solo que aquí hay que evaluar
en x igual a 9 entonces vamos a ver
vamos a ver cómo resolver este problema
vamos a tener que utilizar todas las
propiedades que conocemos de la derivada
entonces tenemos que la derivada con
respecto de x de nuestra función hdx es
exactamente igual que la derivada con
respecto de x y en vez de poner h pues
ponemos esta expresión de hd 3 f x
2 g x muy bien entonces tenemos que
calcular la derivada de esta suma pero
lo que sí sabemos es que la derivada de
una suma de funciones es la suma de las
derivadas esto es la derivada con
respecto de x primero de tres de tres
fd x muy bien esta es la primera
derivada más la derivada con respecto de
x de 2 g de x 2
muy bien esta fue la primera de las
propiedades que tenemos que utilizar la
derivada de una suma es la suma de las
derivadas ahora bien en cada una de
ellas tenemos la derivada de un factor
por la función verdad la derivada de un
número por la función entonces lo que
también sabemos es que esto es
exactamente igual
tres veces la derivada con respecto de x
de nuestra función efe de fx
fx más
dos veces dos veces la derivada con
respecto de x de gd x esta es la segunda
propiedad que conocemos verdad que la
derivada de una constante por una
función es la constante por la derivada
de la función muy bien entonces esto es
exactamente en la derivada de kit de dh
perdón entonces si nosotros queremos
conocer la derivada en 9 en el punto 9
esto no es otra cosa más que o menos si
quien antes lo podemos hacer en general
si nosotros queremos calcular la
derivada de h en cualquier punto esto es
lo mismo que fíjense muy bien tres veces
la derivada de f que es f prima en
cualquier punto x
más dos veces la derivada de g
en ese punto x ahora bien a nosotros nos
interesa calcular la derivada de h en el
punto 9 así que aquí en vez de poner x
podemos poner 9 aquí en lugar de x
podemos poner 9 y aquí también ahora
vamos a utilizar toda esta información
que nos dan para obtener quién es esto
quién es la derivada de h en el punto 9
entonces si nos damos cuenta así podemos
calcular la derivada de f en el punto 9
por ejemplo aquí tenemos en x igual a 9
tenemos cuánto vale la función vale 1
pero eso realmente no es importante lo
que nos interesa es esto cuánto vale su
derivada en el punto 9 así que la
derivada de f en 9 vale 3 ahora bien
cómo podemos calcular la derivada de g
en el punto 9 y para eso voy a hacer una
gráfica
ahí tienen un lg y voy a poner por aquí
el eje x
y ahí tienen ustedes el eje x quizás
debería ser lo más grande
voy a hacerlo un poco más grande
ahí está ahí está el eje x muy bien
digamos que por aquí lo que vamos a
tratar primero de hacer es como como
hemos hecho incluso en algunos vídeos de
valor absoluto es encontrar el mínimo de
esta función porque porque esta función
se ve muy fácil es el valor absoluto de
digamos de una función lineal más
constantes hemos visto que el mínimo o
el máximo de este tipo de funciones se
encuentran muy muy fácil y eso por
ejemplo es minimizando esto verdad este
valor absoluto siempre va a ser mayor o
igual que 0 es decir es no negativo
ahora bien la pregunta es cuando esto
vale 0 que es en donde alcanza su mínimo
esto vale 0 justo cuando esto de aquí
adentro es 0 es decir cuando x es igual
a 1
entonces si x es igual a 1 digamos por
aquí vamos a tener el mínimo si x es
igual a 1 esto se hace cero y la función
g vale 1
entonces vamos a tener este punto es el
mínimo y sabemos que son como como una
especie de flechas o de picos muy bien
ahora para entender muy bien esta
gráfica vamos a escribir ag en dos
pedazos
vamos a tener dos pedazos la primera de
ellas es cuando x es mayor o igual que 1
verdad porque si x es mayor o igual que
este valor absoluto es no negativo es no
negativo es decir bueno siempre es no
negativo sin embargo como x menos 1 es
mayor o igual que 0 se queda igual y me
queda x menos uno más uno pero estos dos
se cancelan y simplemente me queda como
x muy bien entonces la función vale x si
estamos por arriba del 1 el otro caso es
que estemos por abajo de 1 es decir en
este caso x menos 1 es negativo y por lo
tanto su valor absoluto es uno menos
equis y hay que sumarle uno o bien
podemos nosotros simplificar esto como 2
- hechos
y entonces esto es 2 - x entonces
finalmente como se ve la gráfica de esta
función pues si estamos a la derecha del
1 esto se ve como una recta identidad
como la recta identidad y si estamos a
la izquierda del 1 se ve como menos la
identidad desplazada por 2
más o menos así estés digamos la gráfica
de la gráfica gtx muy bien entonces
realmente sólo nos interesa conocer la
pendiente verdad y sólo nos interesa en
el punto 9 entonces por ejemplo digamos
que aquí está el punto 9 lo importante
es que está a la derecha del 1 y
entonces le corresponde esta asignación
es decir aquí la pendiente es la
derivada de x que es uno muy bien
entonces esto de aquí esto de aquí vale
uno y finalmente ya podemos calcular
quién es nuestra derivada porque esto
será 3 por 3 son 9 esto de aquí vale 9
más 2 por la derivada de g 9 es 2 y que
finalmente esto vale 11 muy bien así que
la pendiente de la recta tangente a
nuestra función hdx en el punto 9 o lo
que es lo mismo la derivada en ese punto
es